have had 10 game runs like that  yeah he's hot and you just mentioned you  know look the bucks beat them last time  they matched up well let's go  i don't know what's going on there on  the free throw block out before the shot  but  a big reason the bucks won last time  february 8th when they matched up  jamal murray 11 points that's going to  have to be the case again tonight it's  obviously not going to be jamal murray  scoring 11 points but  it's got to be buck's defensive that  really has been and then creates space  from it and is able to finish and get  the end block will barton back in  murray already with 13 points in the  earlier meeting which the nuggets lost  as you see dozier go out  murray was held to 11 points just four  of 17  in that february eighth game and you  mentioned it in the top katy  got to have murray contributing big time  you totally do